[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hello, and
welcome to episode number
75 of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform" podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
very well, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
Very excited to
have the engineering
director, nonetheless, of
Google Container Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we're going to have
Chen Goldberg joining us.
She is super, super
cool, super, super smart
and very passionate about
containers and open source.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
love how effortlessly
you pronounce her name.
MARK MANDEL: Years of practice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And she's going to be
telling us a little bit
about Kubernetes
itself, but also,
what is the difference between
Kubernetes, Container Engine,
about the community.
It's a very
interesting interview.
I really learned a lot from it.
And then after that,
we have a question
of the week that
comes from Slack.
MARK MANDEL: It does
come from Slack.
One of the users--
I'm going to mispronounce this.
It's like a handle.
Shah_HelloAida.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's words.
We were talking
about Cloud Builder
and how to access
external repositories
if you want to access them
within your build steps.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
We'll have also to
mention real quick what
Cloud Builder is,
because I don't think
we've mentioned it before.
MARK MANDEL: We should
do an episode on that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll do that.
But before that, we have
our Cool Things of the Week,
as usual.
And we have two of them.
You have the one,
I have the one.
So I'm going to let you go
first with the one about,
apparently someone complained
that these had not been
yet a Cool Thing of the Week.
MARK MANDEL: It hasn't been
a Cool Thing of the Week.
We've got to the point
where people are like,
you didn't mention this thing.
We're now mad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I love it.
Yes, so if you haven't looked at
the location section of Google
Cloud Platform and having a
look at all the regions we have,
you may not have noticed
that there is a new Singapore
region that is now available.
So you'll find that there
are two zones in that region,
asia-southeast1a and
asia-southeast1b.
They have lovely Intel Xeon
processors and 64-core machine
types as well as local SSDs
sitting there waiting for you
to take advantage of them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is pretty awesome.
If you are anywhere
around there,
you should be also
able to see GCPing--
MARK MANDEL: GCPing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --being
a little bit faster
if you're closer to one
of those data centers.
So from here in San Francisco,
a little bit far away,
it's actually probably
the farthest away.
MARK MANDEL: I'm getting
174 milliseconds.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that
is the farthest away we are.
That's probably our farthest
data center from San Francisco
right now.
So it makes sense.
But if you're there,
it's way closer.
That makes sense.
So check it out.
I think that not all the
services are available yet,
but you can find
that information
on the Recommendation
page that we
will link from the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
Cool.
So what did you have as a Cool
Thing of the Week, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The second
Cool Thing of the Week
is actually a tweet that
I saw from Prajakta Joshi.
And I checked who she
was, and it turns out
she is a product manager
for Google Cloud Platform.
And she was talking
about the fact
that there is a new thing
supported by HTTP(S) load
balancers, which is WebSockets.
MARK MANDEL: WebSockets!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yay!
It is pretty amazing, because
if I remember correctly,
we actually talked about
how to deal with this not
that long ago.
MARK MANDEL: We did.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
it was not the easiest
or nicest of the experiences.
So it is awesome
that now it is fixed.
So if you want to use
WebSockets over HTTP(S) load
balancer, which is the
global load balancer,
you can just do it.
It is very simple.
We have, as always, a link to
Recommendations from the show
notes.
I don't think there's much to
say other than it just works.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It looks really, really cool.
It is worth noting that
if you have configured
client IP or a generated
code session affinity
for your load balancers, then
your WebSocket connections
from a client are sent to
the same back-end instance.
So it respects the
sticky sessions.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which is
important for WebSockets,
obviously.
MARK MANDEL: But,
otherwise, it looks
like it's just really good
to go, which is great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So that's awesome.
I'm very happy about it.
And also, I did not know
about Prajakta Joshi,
so I searched on Google,
and I saw that she also
talked at GCP Next.
She seems really
cool, so if you're
listening to this, Prajakta,
you're very, very, very invited
to come and join on the podcast
and talk about a little bit
networking and all
the cool things
in Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
Definitely.
Awesome.
Well, why don't we go
have a chat with Chen
and talk to her all
about GKE and Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
So it's an honor today for
me to welcome the engineering
director of GKE,
nonetheless, Chen Goldberg.
How are you doing?
CHEN GOLDBERG: Great.
I'm very happy to be here.
Thank you for inviting me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very happy.
We met at a party
right after Cloud Next,
and since then I
really, really wanted
you to come to the podcast and
tell us a little bit about how
it is to be working at GKE.
But before you start
talking about GKE
and all the details of
Kubernetes and all that cool
stuff, why don't you tell us
a little bit about who you are
and what you do at Google?
CHEN GOLDBERG: So, I am
an engineering manager.
That means that I'm
passionate about building
teams and helping building
teams to be productive
and building products that
consumers and users like.
And while I've always been
very drawn to infrastructure,
I was able to bring
that passion to users
into the infrastructure world.
And at Google, I'm
doing my dream job.
Open source means
building a huge team.
And [INAUDIBLE] helping
making sure that the community
is productive and
a happy community.
And we have a great
product at GKE.
So I'm having a great time.
MARK MANDEL: All right, cool.
So why don't we start
with an easy question.
So what is GKE?
What is Google Container Engine?
CHEN GOLDBERG: Google
Container Engine
is a platform that
helps you manage
your containerized applications
the same as Google does.
We in Google have been
managing applications
within containers like Gmail
and Maps for over 12 years now.
And with GKE, we're able
to provide the same service
and offerings to Google
Cloud Platform users.
This means that when
you are choosing GKE,
you can really focus on
developing your application.
And GKE allows you to quickly
deploy your application
and make it available
to users as a service.
And we are responsible
for all the productization
of your service.
And the differentiation is,
it's an amazing technology
of Kubernetes, which
is the heart of GKE,
together with Google Cloud
Platform in general, which
means all the goodness of Google
network and storage and machine
learning that is available.
And on top of
everything, I think
what's very unique
for Google and we
are known for is our
operational excellence.
Our site reliability
engineers and the practices
that we have built
throughout the years
are being implemented
for users through GKE.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
not that long ago, we
had an amazing episode.
We had the chance to
have John Wilkes talking
about Borg and Kubernetes.
But for those that
have not listened
to any of our
Kubernetes episodes,
could you tell us a little bit
about like, why is Kubernetes
a thing?
What is cool about it?
CHEN GOLDBERG: Everything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Of course.
CHEN GOLDBERG: As I
said before, Kubernetes
is the heart of Google
Container Engine.
It's an open source platform for
automating deployment, scaling,
and operations of containerized
applications across clusters.
With Kubernetes,
you're able, once you
are familiar with
containers and you
have microservice
applications, you
are able to deploy your
applications quickly
in a predictable way and
scale on the fly, which
means that it's very easy to
meet changing demand together
with Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So then what's the
difference or possibly
the relationship between
Kubernetes and Container
Engine?
How does that work?
CHEN GOLDBERG:
The first thing is
that Kubernetes is open
source, and it runs anywhere.
This is also the
main differentiation
between Borg, our
internal container-centric
infrastructure, and Kubernetes.
For the team that
founded Kubernetes,
it was very important
to make it open source,
because we understand that Cloud
today, while we see that it's
a very popular trend,
still most of the workloads
are not running in Cloud.
But they are running on-premise.
So we know that if people
want to move to containers
and they want to be agile
and to quickly deploy,
they are actually looking
to do it not in the cloud
but in other environments.
So the team really
wanted to make
something open source that
it would be easily adopted.
So that's one.
And the second thing is that
by making it open source,
we are building a very
rich ecosystem around it.
So you have many
other tools that
are bridging that gap, if its on
developer experience, security,
storage, and network and more.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So then
that means that, basically, I
can get Kubernetes and
run it basically anywhere.
And every single time I say you
can run Kubernetes everywhere,
it comes to my mind the
demo that Ray Tsang did,
where he runs Kubernetes on a
cloud server of Raspberry Pis.
So it is like one on top of
each other, which is very cool.
So you can run it
virtually anywhere,
but we offer a way to run it on
GKE, Google Container Engine.
What is the benefit of running
it on Google Container Engine
rather than just installing
it on your own cluster?
CHEN GOLDBERG: First
of all, just spinning
off a new cluster in Kubernetes
is not something hard to do,
OK?
We actually invested a lot
in making it easy, with tools
like kubeadm, and
we even emphasized
that it would be easy
in a consistent way
across different platforms,
wherever you run it.
The value of GKE,
or Container Engine,
is by the offering
of what happens next.
So you spin off your cluster.
This is great.
Then even you start to
deploy your application
on that cluster.
How do you keep the
cluster updated?
How do you get the most
recent Kubernetes versions?
Google Container Engine is
where 1.6 is already available.
We are always the first one to
make innovation of Kubernetes
available within the
Kubernetes community.
And we are doing it without
compromising quality.
So when we make it available
on GKE, we have tested it,
and we make sure that it will
work well for our customers.
We are upgrading
automatically both the master,
the control plane of the
cluster, and the nodes.
And we provide you out of
the box the integration
to everything that you
need to actually serve
customers for your application.
So integration with network
and load balancing and storage
and just solving all
the infrastructure
challenges for you.
What I often hear from
developers is two things.
GKE is the best and easiest
way to try out Kubernetes,
because it's so easy
to spin off a cluster.
But the more
important thing, it's
the easiest and fastest way
to make your application
productized.
So if you are a
startup, for example,
and you want to quickly
set up something and maybe
serve in multiregions, GKE and
GCPs is a very easy way to go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
you mentioned updates.
And I'm curious about that
because since Kubernetes
is built for failure, for
resilience against failure,
I'm assuming that that might
help with update procedures.
But how does it work?
Do I even care when the update
happens from 1.5 to 1.6,
for instance?
CHEN GOLDBERG: So
first of all, this
is some of our secret sauce
of how we do it in GKE.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
CHEN GOLDBERG: And,
no, you shouldn't care.
And of course we make sure that
we will not introduce risks.
There is a way, if
someone wants to opt out,
but within Kubernetes,
we are making sure
that we are backward compatible.
We can upgrade for you.
And usually you don't
know and you don't care.
The machines themselves that are
part of the Kubernetes clusters
are more tricky.
This is area where some would
prefer to opt out of those
capabilities, especially if
they have in their application
design some constraints
that we cannot foresee.
But overall we are
making the upgrade
while we mitigate
the risk, making
sure your application continues
to serve as you would expect.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's cool.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And you talked about
it a little bit,
but I'd love to hear
some more detail.
So, GKE was to integrate
it more with GCP,
there were certain things out
of the box that were available.
Can you talk a bit about the
sort of features and tools
that are directly integrated
into the hosted Kubernetes
solution that we run?
CHEN GOLDBERG: I think the
most thing to highlight
is the infrastructure.
For example, RVMs, powered
by a Google Compute Engine.
You can have flexible machines.
You can decide exactly
what types of machines
you will have, if they are
the fastest to start up.
This is very unique to GCP.
Network, of course,
works out of the box.
We allow you to integrate
into the IM capabilities
of the rest of GCP.
And also what we lately
see more and more
is how GKE customers are
leveraging the machine learning
services available on GCP.
So those are just a few
examples of the power of GKE
together with GCP.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So let's talk a
little bit about GKE.
We just had the 1.6 version
of Kubernetes released,
and you mentioned that it
is already available on GKE.
What is the coolest
thing, in your opinion?
What is your favorite feature
of all the things that are new?
CHEN GOLDBERG: I am excited
usually about the big things
that we are trying
to do, and then there
are multiple features that
allow us to move forward.
Aparna, in her keynote
at KubeCon in Berlin
when we announced
1.6, was talking
about how Kubernetes
is moving forward
in supporting multiworkloads
and multiusers at scale.
And to me that's
the exciting part
that I look forward this
year with Kubernetes.
When you are running
your applications
at scale within a
cluster, this is where
it becomes the most efficient.
This is where it's exciting.
This is where you need to
invest less in operating
the cluster itself.
So there are two examples
of features that are really
helping us move forward there.
One is supporting 5,000
nodes of a single cluster.
This is also available on GCP.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is huge.
MARK MANDEL: That's good.
CHEN GOLDBERG: But it's
not just about right size.
It's not all that matters.
We have, for example,
introduced a better
what we call RBAC, Role-Based
Access Control, which gives you
more [? generality ?] of
permissions within a cluster.
So if before it was harder
to have multiple teams,
for example, work
within a cluster.
It meant that you were forced
to have multiple clusters.
Now that's no longer the case.
And I think that's
the most exciting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Basically
the whole idea here
is that, rather than
having-- like at a startup,
you have maybe three clusters
for three different teams
working together.
Now you have one cluster that
might be a little bit bigger
but now you have all the
things running together.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is really cool.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Yes,
and just to make sure
that we don't confuse
anyone, we still
recommend separating development
environment from production
environment.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
a very good point.
CHEN GOLDBERG: But other
than that, definitely
having multiple teams
or multiple services,
even in production, serving
from the same cluster.
MARK MANDEL: So just from
an outside perspective,
or even from an
inside perspective,
it seems like the community
surrounding Kubernetes is just
growing by leaps and bounds,
even in the last six months
to a year.
Do you have any
involvement in that?
CHEN GOLDBERG: Yes.
I think this was what was most
exciting for me in this role,
is helping to build
this community.
Kubernetes as an
open source project
is very unique for the reason
that we encourage and we
want to have more contribution.
So we are actively
working on increasing
the percentage of Google
contribution into Kubernetes.
When we started, Googlers
contributed 76% of the commits,
and right now it's
in the low 40s.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
CHEN GOLDBERG: And it's not
like my team is not growing.
We grow fast.
We're still hiring, if
anyone is interested.
It is just that we make sure
that the community grows
even faster than we do.
And that's important for us.
We've found that a product
or technology like Kubernetes
will not be
successful without it.
Let's take the promise
of "runs anywhere."
For that, we need users to
actually run it anywhere.
We know we don't do it.
We know that we are
experienced with our GKE users
and what we know
from Google, but we
have Red Hat, for
example, or CoreOS.
They are running on-premise
Kubernetes and managing it.
Their feedback is very
important for the community.
We see others that are helping
with developer experience
and simplification and
network and security.
Just having all of
those expertise together
and getting that
feedback really fast
is what makes Kubernetes
so special in my mind.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I guess we've
been talking around this topic
for basically the whole time.
But we keep on talking
about community,
and I guess that the fact
that it is open source
helps the community,
but not only.
Can you tell us a little
bit about why is Kubernetes
open source to start with?
CHEN GOLDBERG: So, first of
all, as engineering managers
or in general as
engineers, I think
it's very hard to
compete with technologies
that are not open source.
I mean, there is a
limit of how many people
a single company can put
into a single product.
And I think it's something that
is very clear with Kubernetes.
The amount of investment
right now, it was calculated,
it's about 400
engineering years already.
That's huge.
I don't have such a
big team to support it.
I mean, for me as an engineering
manager, and also the team,
we think that innovation
pace is unmatchable
when choosing open source.
And also for Google
specifically, I
think open matters,
open source matters,
but it matters more in Cloud.
We talked about the
portability aspect,
which is very important.
We keep saying to our customers,
we want you to have a choice.
So you have the freedom to
come to Google Cloud Platform,
but also have the
freedom to leave.
We want you to stay because
this is the best cloud for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Obviously.
MARK MANDEL: We're biased.
CHEN GOLDBERG: But people can
leave, and they choose to stay.
Openness is not
just about choosing
the platform but
also the flexibility
on which tools to use.
There are so many CI/CD tools.
And that, by the
way, keeps changing.
And there will be
always new technologies.
So by making it open source,
we know that new technologies
will continue to be
introduced into Kubernetes
and supported because it's
open source, because it's
easy to do it.
And when building a
community in Kubernetes,
we invest probably half of our
time in building Kubernetes
as a technology and
half of the time
around building the
community and making
it easy to develop
on top of Kubernetes.
So if I'm now a
startup that wants
to integrate into
Kubernetes or just
a vendor or even an
enterprise customer,
I think this is a reason
why they like open source.
You can tailor it
to your own needs.
And we invest a lot
in extensibility.
We care about fragmentation
and in general making sure
that the success of
Kubernetes is sustainable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So you're talking about
the fact that there's
a very big interest in people
building on top of Kubernetes.
And we've actually
interviewed Helm.
We've interviewed a bunch
of different people building
stuff, like fission also
is on top of Kubernetes,
a bunch of different projects
that run on Kubernetes,
which is amazing.
So what is the coolest or
the most interesting one
that you have seen lately?
CHEN GOLDBERG: I wouldn't
say the most interesting,
but I can say something
that I was passionate about.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let's go with that.
CHEN GOLDBERG: What I
was investing more in
is definitely Helm.
Kubernetes started with very
infrastructure-oriented people,
many ops people.
And last year our
main focus was making
sure it's easy for developers
to start using Kubernetes.
And I don't think
we are done yet,
but with Helm, I think it's
amazing the amount of charts
that we have that support
multiple workloads,
different types of workloads.
And we make sure that
everything that we produce--
and we say "we" because it's
a community effort, of course,
led by Deis team, to make
sure that everything is tested
and that when we
release new releases,
we want to make sure that things
are still working as expected.
So that's one thing
that I'm really
excited about from within
the Kubernetes community.
But that's just one example.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's awesome.
Since you're mentioning
Deis, they were on the news
not that long ago, because
they are joining Microsoft.
What is your view
on all of this?
What do you think?
CHEN GOLDBERG: First
of all, I think
this is exciting for
the Kubernetes community
because this is just evidence
to show how companies realize
the value of Kubernetes.
And it also validates our belief
that developers want openness
and flexibility in the cloud.
More specifically
for Deis, Deis are
friends and a very
important member
of the community of Kubernetes.
And I'm really happy for them.
And I hope that with
this acquisition,
they can do more for Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
Well, we're kind of
running out of time.
But is there anything
else that you
would like to add, any
topic that we've forgotten,
or anything else that
you'd just like to mention?
CHEN GOLDBERG: Yes.
We haven't touched it.
We talked about
technology and openness,
but one thing that I am
passionate about, definitely
as an engineering
manager, is about building
the right culture.
And I think that the right
recipe to build a strong team
is having a very strong
culture and set of values.
That's the thing I like
the most about Kubernetes.
It's about openness and
appreciating feedback,
inclusiveness, and diversity.
From the moment I joined
Kubernetes community,
I felt comfortable
and respected.
I hope everybody
else feels like that,
and I would welcome
everybody to join us.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
So to segue from
there, if people
want to get involved with
the Kubernetes community,
where should they go?
CHEN GOLDBERG: That's
a good question.
Kubernetes can be
very overwhelming
with the size of it.
We have a concept which we
call special interest groups.
They are smaller groups
within the community
of people working together on an
area they are passionate about.
There is about 25
of these, and we
can add in the notes
exactly linked to that.
I think the best way is just to
choose an area you care about
and join one of these
special interest groups.
Then you will know
the people by name,
you can see the faces
on the GVC or Zoom
or whatever meeting tool
you will be using there.
That would probably
be the easiest one.
I can highlight one specific.
We have the Contrib
Experience special interest
group, which is focusing on
the contributor experience.
So even if you know
nothing about Kubernetes,
but you know something
about developer experience
and open source, that
will be the easiest way
to get involved.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's great.
We will have a bunch of
links from the show notes
to point to of those
special interest groups.
And also we'll have a bunch
of links to different talks
from KubeCon.
I know that your
keynote was really good,
so if people are interested
in learning more,
I think it's a very
good place to go to.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Chen, thank you
so much for joining us.
It was super great to
have you on the podcast.
CHEN GOLDBERG:
Thank you very much.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks again
to Chen for joining us.
It was really great to
have a chat with her
and hear about her opinions
and her perspective
on Container Engine
and Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and just talking to her,
because she's awesome.
Now we're going for our Question
of the Week, and as we said,
it is a Question of the
Week coming from Slack,
from the username Shah_HelloAida
or something like that.
So the question is,
if I want to access
private repo from Container
Builder, how do I do it?
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So this just depends.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I guess before we start
answering the question,
we should mention
what are those things?
What is Container Builder?
And what is a private repo?
So Container Builder?
MARK MANDEL: Container
Builder is essentially
an automated system for building
containers on Google Platform.
It can be fired manually,
so you can actually
run it locally to basically use
the cloud to build containers
in the cloud.
But you can also have
it run on say, WAN,
and Git repo gets pushed
to, or something like that,
and then have it
trigger automatically.
It can have multiple build
steps and can do more than just
building a simple container.
So it's a pretty
nice little piece
of foundation work for
building continuous integration
and continuous delivery systems.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
What I like about it is the
fact that it allows you to build
containers very easily,
and you can run it directly
from Gcloud Container
Build, submit something.
You don't need to install
Docker on your machine.
If you don't have
it, that's fine.
You can still build
your containers
and push it to the container
repository, well, Container
Registry.
Actually, and then
access it from there.
So that's pretty awesome.
So to do that, Container Builder
accesses repos and downloads
code from places.
And when it's a public
repo, no matter where it is,
well, it's public,
so you can access it.
But what if it's private?
MARK MANDEL: OK, so
you're working probably
on some sort of
commercial application.
You don't want it to be
exposed the outside world.
There's a couple
of options here.
So Google Cloud
Platform does allow you
to have source repositories.
They are private repositories,
private Git repositories
that come with Google
Cloud Platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
they're pretty awesome.
I use them all the time.
MARK MANDEL: I use them, too.
They're really super simple.
So if you're running
Google Cloud Builder
in the same project as
the source repository
that you have your
code in, then there's
not going to be a problem.
It should be able to grab
that code, pull it down,
do what it needs to do.
Sweet.
It's perfect.
If you have your
source repository
in a different
project, you will need
to configure some permissions
on that repository
so that your external
repository can then access it.
So basically give that Builder
project access to that source
repository so it can do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Makes sense.
MARK MANDEL: If you have
something like a private Git
repo on, say, like,
GitHub, then we're
going to need to
get some SSH keys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
how do you do that?
MARK MANDEL: How do we do that?
So in the future,
hopefully, this
should be a whole lot easier
and there will be no steps.
The solution we talk
about having now
basically is, store those
keys in a private Google Cloud
Storage bucket.
So put them somewhere so that
the outside world can't get
to them but that project can.
And then, within
your build step, just
download those keys from
that Git storage bucket,
put them in the
appropriate space,
probably in an SSH
folder, and then you'll
be able to access your Git
repository pretty much exactly
as you would do normally.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I wonder if it
could be also doable
if you started a metadata
server or something like that.
But it's probably easier to
do it on Google Cloud Storage.
That's actually something
that people do not realize.
You can just drag and drop
files from your desktop
to the bucket, which
is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty easy.
Then you've got also
a lot of control
because you have all the ACLs,
the Access Control Lists,
and that kind of stuff as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's a very
good reason to do it that way.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so Container
Builder, pretty flexible.
You can do a lot with it.
It's actually
really, really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it
is definitely worth trying.
I'm going to be
playing with it soon,
because there's this new
thing, the Docker Build, that
is multistep.
I don't know if
you heard about it.
MARK MANDEL: I have not.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It allows
you to do things like,
when you want to build
something and you
want to put all your tooling
and compilers and stuff,
and then you want to
generate a binary.
And you want that binary to
be in the smallest container
image possible.
So it allows you
to do exactly that.
MARK MANDEL: That's similar
to what I do by hand.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
Less meg files.
I know, it may sound
a little bit sad
for you to have less meg files.
It's actually a good thing.
So I'm going to play
with that, and I'm
pretty sure that Container
Builder is a very nice way
to do that.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
I think we're going to have
to look at that a little bit
later.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: What are you up to?
What are you doing?
Where are you going?
Anything interesting
on the calendar?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So by the
time this episode comes out,
I'll be already in New York.
And I had presented
already last Monday,
May 1, the Google Developer
Group, New York City,
talking about end points
with our dear friend Brett.
He will be talking
about cloud functions.
And after that, I'll
be back right on time
for Google I/O. I will not
be going to Google I/O,
but on May 15, I will be hosting
Gopherfest San Francisco, which
is a very cool event hosted
here in San Francisco,
in the launchpad, which is
by the San Francisco office.
Lots of cool talks about
Go, community, et cetera.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
The week that this
podcast comes out,
I'll be helping host the Extra
Life and Playcrafting Game Jam.
We will be raising money
for kids in hospital.
Then I don't go anywhere for
a week, which is really nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Crazy.
MARK MANDEL: And then,
the week after that, I
go to Sweden to Nordic
Game Conference, where
I'm off to talk about Kubernetes
and game servers and all
the good stuff there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And right after that, it will
be right after Google I/O,
so there will be some fresh
announcements probably.
MARK MANDEL: There
will be something.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We should do
a special episode or something.
MARK MANDEL: Something like that
sounds like a reasonable thing
to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll see
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Francesc, thank
you again for joining me
for yet another
episode of the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]